hi everyone so I'm making an
announcement today and I suppose you
might regard it as an advertisement so
I'm warning you to begin with because I
don't want you to waste your time if
you're not interested in listening to a
description of the newest thing that
we've created so we just put up a
website called understand myself calm
and it's a personality assessment for
individuals and it's based on a
personality model that was developed in
my lab about ten years ago by dr. Colin
D young and lean dr. lena quilty dr. de
young is now a professor at the
University of Minnesota and it was based
on some ideas that I had been developing
with another former student of mine dr.
Daniel Higgins who's a partner with me
and this enterprise along with my former
graduate supervisor dr. Robert Peel from
McGill University it's based on the Big
Five personality model which measures
extraversion which is a positive emotion
dimension and is associated with
gregariousness and enthusiasm and
assertiveness and sociability and that
sort of thing and a trait called
neuroticism which is basically negative
emotionality which is associated with a
proclivity towards anxiety and emotional
pain agreeableness which is compassion
and politeness and so agreeable people
are I would say broadly speaking rather
maternal in their orientation they tend
to care more for others than for
themselves
they're more cooperative than
competitive whereas so-called
disagreeable people are more competitive
and more brusque I would say and perhaps
more straightforward and more able to
stand up for themselves as well
conscientiousness is another one of the
dimensions that's orderliness and
industriousness and the last dimension
is opens to experience which is a
combination of interest in ideas which
is often known as intellect and interest
in aesthetics and which is associated
let's say with creativity and that's the
dimension that's also most highly
correlated with IQ we developed the big
five aspect scale in an attempt to take
the big five so that's extraversion
neuroticism agreeableness conch
justice and openness to experience which
are the canonical dimensions of
personality we developed the big5 aspect
scale in order to break down those big
five traits each of them into their two
most statistically robust sub components
and we call those aspects and that's
actually become a pretty popular
personality model the scientific paper
which announced that statistical
division has accrued about 750 citations
which is an awful lot of citations by
the way for a scientific paper it makes
it into a kind of classic especially
because it's only also only had ten
years to accrue citations and a citation
is when some other scientist refers to
the paper in one of their papers by the
way anyways I've been working over the
last couple of years to generate really
detailed personality reports on each of
the big five traits and the ten aspects
at about seven different levels of
specificity ranging from extremely low
to extremely high and we think we've
produced what might be the most
comprehensive and accurate personality
reports that are currently available you
answer a hundred questions in order to
complete the personality survey the
questions themselves are actually public
access or you could call them open
source they were derived from Lew
Goldberg's IP IP international
personality item pool they're the
consequence of many many decades of
attempts to define a set of phrases that
most comprehensively and also most
concisely captures the variation in
human personality and so you can find
those questions many places on the line
but the reports themselves and the
comparison sample of approximately
10,000 people are proprietary and
constitute the central element of value
in in our offering essentially and what
we're hoping is that people can use this
personality test site to develop a much
deeper understanding of themselves so
that they know what they're like
especially compared to others and that
they can also compare themselves to
anyone else for example who might have
taken the test and see the thing about
personality is that the differences
between people actually run quite deep
there's a lot of individual variability
so there are people who are extreme
extraverted they want to spend every
moment of their time socializing with
other people and there are people who
are very introverted and they want to
work alone and they find interactions
with with large groups of people or even
small groups sometimes quite tiring and
they have to spend a lot of time
recovering they tend to be much more
quiet they're not necessarily shy
because that shyness is more consequence
of variation on the second dimension
neuroticism and so people are high in
neuroticism I feel much more anxiety and
emotional pain per unit of uncertainty
and stress than people who are very low
in neuroticism who are often known as
emotionally stable and who tend to be
quite imperturbable agreeable people as
I mentioned before are warm and
compassionate and and very much care for
other people but are also likely to be
taken advantage of and to feel a certain
amount of resentment whereas
disagreeable people are tough and
straightforward and competitive and out
for victory but can also be somewhat
self-centered and harsh and then
conscientious people are hardworking and
dutiful conscientiousness is a really
good predictor of long-term life success
especially in academic attainment where
it's second only to IQ and also in
managerial and administrative jobs that
require attention to detail and a fair
bit of responsibility let's say and
routine work open this to experience
that's the creativity dimension and some
people are extremely high and openness
to experience and they want to do
nothing but discuss ideas and and spend
their time in creative and artistic
pursuits and other people are more
conservative because low openness is
associated with conservatism and they're
not really interested in novel ideas and
they don't think abstractly that often
and they're they're not out for new
experiences or flights of fantasy or
imaginative exercises or any of that
thing there are a lot more concrete and
practical now the reports that we've
prepared not only provide you with
information about all of the
aforementioned big five traits they also
break each one down into its dual
aspects so there's actually 15 different
sources of information that are
contained in the reports and so for
extraversion you get a description of
the degree to which you're assertive
which means forthcoming let's say in
public and willing to put your opinions
forward
and enthusiasm which is a more pure
marker of positive emotion and the
capacity to look forward to and enjoy
events and situations spontaneously and
with neuroticism you learn about the
trait aspects withdrawal and volatility
and withdrawal is the tendency to be
stymied or or stopped let's say by fear
to be frozen in some sense like a prey
animal and volatility is an aspect
that's associated with irritability and
the tendency to be easily rubbed the
wrong way let's say and to react
emotionally to that and then for
agreeableness there's two aspects and
one is compassion which means pretty
much what it says it's the ability to
embody the feelings of others and to
react in a caring manner to that and
politeness which seems to be something
like respect for authority and social
conventions and so one of the things you
see for example is that liberals are
higher in compassion and conservatives
are higher in politeness even though
they're both aspects of trait
agreeableness conscientiousness breaks
down into two aspects as well which are
quite interesting one of them is
industriousness which is associated with
diligent hard work and the ability to
stay task focused without distraction
and to work hard and orderliness which
seems to be associated with disgust
sensitivity and which is a pretty good
predictor of conservative belief as it
turns out that some elements of
conservative belief are associated with
higher than normal levels of or higher
than average let's say levels of disgust
sensitivity and the final trait division
in two aspects is that of openness to
experience and it can be divided into
openness proper which is essentially a
dimension of creativity and aesthetic
sensitivity so preference for engagement
activities that are associated say with
fiction or drama or art and intellect
which is an index of interest in ideas
and abstraction and philosophical
concepts and that sort of things so the
report produces a very high resolution
representation of personality and there
are very interesting differences at the
aspect level that are worth
concentrating on we try to develop a
personality test that isn't designed to
make you feel good
yourself although it might you know it
depends on your personality but to give
you the most accurate and
straightforward description of who you
are that's possible so that you can use
the genuine information that's provided
in order to maybe organize your life
also understand the difference between
yourself and other people because you
know we often think that the reason that
we don't share the same viewpoint is
because we have differences of opinion
but it actually goes a lot deeper than
that because you're very perceptions are
dependent on the variability in your
personality and so it isn't only that
people differ in their opinions they
differ very much in how they see the
world how they actually perceive the
world because your personality
constitutes a kind of template or filter
through which you organize your
perceptions and so it's very important
to understand that there is substantial
personality variability in the world and
that you're often talking with people
who see things differently than you and
a good example of that is the divide
between let's say left-leaning people
and right leading people because the
left-leaning people tend to be very high
and openness to experience and
relatively low in conscientiousness
especially in the aspect of orderliness
whereas the conservative types tend to
be very high in conscientiousness
especially orderliness and relatively
low and openness and so those are
fundamentally different orientations in
the world and you could say that the
more conservative types the more
right-wing types are much more concerned
with the preservation of tradition and
tend to believe that things that have
been done the tried-and-true manner in
the past are the most reliable whereas
the people who are on the Left who are
more radical are more concerned with the
fact that the environment shifts
radically and rapidly and unpredictably
and so we have to be willing to shift
with it and so those are both valid
viewpoints because every element of
lived experience has an orderly element
and a chaotic element let's say and you
have to be prepared for both and the
purpose of straightforward political
dialogue between people of different
personality types is to help determine
on an ongoing basis how much we should
be relying on tradition and how much we
should be attempting to transform
ourselves and there's no permanent
solution to that problem because things
stay the same and
and they do that at different rates at
different times so dialogue is
unbelievably important which by the way
is why I'm such an advocate let's say
for free speech because it's the
mechanism that keeps people of different
types speaking instead of fighting so
it's really important so anyways the
website is called understand myself calm
and you can go there and sign up for the
personality test it'll be delivered to
you pretty much immediately after you
fill out the questions each question is
posed as a phrase
take you about 15 minutes to complete
the questions you can only do it once
and the reason for that is is that the
norms that we compared you against so
that would be the self reports of the
10,000 other people against whom you're
compared they were only allowed to do it
once and so we have to maintain
stringent control over that to maintain
the validity of the test and I would say
don't do it when you're hungry don't do
it when you're tired don't do it when
you're feeling down or in a bad mood
about yourself or feeling self-critical
and don't do it when you're likely to be
interrupted or distracted you want to
take it seriously and you want to think
about your answers now you're supposed
to answer as you are typically not as
you'd like to be and you know you don't
want to be either too hard on yourself
or too good to yourself you want to be
as accurate as possible because then
you'll benefit most from the feedback
and then the last thing I would say is
that we've some of you know about this
already but we've also developed a set
of interventions called self authoring
and that's available at self authoring
calm and what self are thering can help
you do is reconfigure certain elements
of your behavior and perhaps over the
long run your personality so the self
authoring suite helps you write an
autobiography and and detail out the
both positive and negative experiences
of your past so that you can capitalize
on the positive experiences and figure
out how to duplicate them and maybe put
the negative experiences to rest and we
feel that that's a good way to reduce
trait neuroticism over the long run and
the evidence for that is that writing
programs of this sort tend to improve
people's mental health and decrease
their negative emotion so and and
stabilize them so so if you take the
personality test and you're not how
for example with your scores on trait
neuroticism you feel that you would
benefit from some additional emotional
stability then the past authoring
program from the self authoring suite
might be something worth considering and
then with regards to the other
personality traits um the present
authoring program at self authoring com
is also a personality exercise of a sort
but what it helps you do is Center on
your virtues and your faults using a Big
Five model again so that you can
identify what's good about your
personality and figure out how to
capitalize that on that in the future
and so that you can identify where your
major weaknesses are and figure out how
to rectify those and so that's useful
for general personality work I would say
and then the last one which we've done
the most research on is called future
authoring and the future authoring
program helps you think about your life
and we think about it as an adjunct to
conscientiousness perhaps over the long
run and also as an exercise that could
increase positive and decrease negative
emotion bias by helping you establish
your goals and also stabilizing your
view of the world so in the future
authoring program you're asked to
consider your life along about seven
dimensions so friendship intimate
relationships what you do outside of
work with your private life in terms of
useful and creative activity or
enjoyable activity or social activity
what you're aiming for in your career
how you're going to configure your self
education how you're going to take care
of yourself mentally and physically and
how are you going to handle your use of
drugs and alcohol because those are
pitfalls that people often encounter
that tear them down and hurt them badly
and so you're asked to think about
yourself three to five years down the
road as if you were taking care of
yourself
as if you were a valuable person you
know because you want to extend that
courtesy to yourself because you're as
valuable on average as anyone else and
you should treat yourself that way so
anyways you're asked to design a future
three to five years down the road where
your experience along each of those
dimensions is optimized and then you're
asked right for 15 minutes about what
your life could be like three to five
years down the road if you were taking
care of yourself
the way you should and things were
working out properly so you could
imagine that you're developing a vision
of the life that you'd like to lead and
then you're asked to reverse that and to
write for 15 minutes and think about
this as well about what your life would
be like if you let your bad habits and
your characterological weaknesses take
the upper hand and auger you into the
ground so that you became you know a
failure and bitter and resentful and
isolated and unhappy and and all of the
terrible things that go along with bad
luck and and also missed opportunities
and let's call them ethical errors so
and then you're asked to take your
positive vision for the future and
elaborate that out into a detailed plan
where you justify your your goals you
you describe what those goals are you
rank order them in importance you
describe how you would be better and
your family would be better and your
society would be better if you stuck to
your goals
you make a contract with yourself to
determine how it is that you're going to
approach those goals and stay on path
and and so forth and so these are quite
extensive exercises and we developed
them you might say as an alternative to
lengthy and expensive psychotherapy and
there's a fair bit of research evidence
suggesting that writing exercises of
this sort are extremely effective ways
of reconfiguring the manner in which you
approach the world and so the research
we've done for example in three
different locations now and with with
several thousand college students
although this is not a program only
designed for college students has
indicated that even if you do a
relatively poor job of let's say the
future authoring program and you're a
college student it increases the
probability that you'll stay in your
program by about 25% which is a
walloping improvement and also has about
the same effect on your grade point
average and so that seems to be
particularly true for people who are
doing the worst so it's been really
effective for disenchanted ethnic
minority males in Holland for example
compared to the Dutch national females
who do better than anyone else in the
sample that we looked at two years after
the entire group did the future
authoring program the ethnic minority
males who were underperforming by about
eighty percent
and slightly exceeded the performance of
the Dutch national women so that was
absolutely staggering result as far as
we're concerned and we also duplicated
that at a place in Canada called Mohawk
College showing that the program worked
particularly effectively for men again
for males who are underperforming
females generally speaking in the
academic world and especially if they
were males who hadn't done that well in
high school and hadn't carved out a very
specified route forward in their
academic achievement so it's an
excellent way of getting your act
together and so anyways the understand
myself comm page is designed to give you
a picture of your personality in detail
and then the self authoring program is
designed to help you reconfigure the way
that you approach life and so we're
hoping that the combination of those two
things are a particularly effective way
of bringing high quality psychological
information and advice and help to a
very broad audience at a very low cost
and at a relative minimum of demands on
time I would say we do know with the
self authoring program that the more you
write the better it works which is sort
of tantamount to saying that the program
works better in your life gets better
the more you think about the future
which really stands to reason but it's
nice to see that actually represented
and duplicated as part of a scientific
research project so anyways we've tried
to keep the programs as reliable as
possible as straightforward as possible
as dependent on your own actions as
possible because the writing is really
crucial to reconfiguring your
personality and as widely distributed
well and is low cost as we can possibly
manage we're trying to provide you with
accurate psychological information so
that you understand yourself and other
people better and so that your life can
be configured in a manner that I hope is
much more beneficial to you personnel
personally and helpful to your family
and also has a positive effect on the
broader society around you because
that's a great triumvirate of attainment
and it's exactly what you should be
aiming for so I would say I encourage
you to determine who you are and to
think about that very carefully and then
to determine very carefully who you want
to be and why and to make a plan you
know you don't get the opportunity to do
that in school
junior high high school college
university no one ever sits you down and
helps you figure out where you came from
and who you are and what you're doing
and you really need to know that I
should also say that with the understand
myself comm site we're also working on
our couples module that will enable the
people who have filled out the report to
ask someone else to also do the
questionnaire and then they'll both get
a report that details out their
similarities and differences so that
they can come to understand where
they're going to be in agreement and get
along and share interests and where
they're likely to have conflict and what
might be done about that and I would say
that's at minimum a month to two months
away and we're also going to release a
high school version of the self
authoring suite so that people can start
to plan their lives when they're much
younger and we'll only ask the high
school students to think about three to
six months out into the future because
when you're that young that's about the
practical limit of your I wouldn't say
ability to think forward into the future
but the younger you are the shorter your
time horizon partly because well you you
haven't been exposed to the world that
much and there's you still have plenty
to learn so but anyways we have a high
school version in the works and so I'll
announce that when it comes out and so
we all hope that you find these
offerings useful and practical and and
that they help you put your life
together so that you can be a solid
citizen and a responsible person and as
emotionally stable as possible and maybe
even find some happiness along the way
from time to time so that would be
really good
you